it's your boy swifty blue check me out
on the bullet cat podcast
boo lakehead podcast special guest in
here my guy swifty blue welcome whoa
whoa welcome welcome first of all you've
been killing it you obviously you put
the group album out with uh money signed
suede and uh shout out to peso is he
still locked free peso yeah still locked
up free peso he's like a kid right isn't
he like 16 years he's my son
free my stepson i had to adopt his ass
yeah he's like a young child man
he's a knucklehead yeah
yeah have you you keep in communication
with him uh he just called me like
yesterday the day before yesterday
is he allowed to talk to you are you
guys allowed to talk to each other whoa
he gets phone calls he gets phone calls
like
like two times a week or something like
that well i know you recently were
locked up so i don't know if you're
allowed to talk to like i'm good now i'm
are you off paper i'm not you exactly
i'm i'm not on no papers so you're free
from the system finally from the system
man i'm like come on man let's go hard
what up we gotta interrupt the interview
real quick to tell you about our people
at blue chew don't forget to go to
bluetooth.com
use the promo code bootleg right now and
get your first month free all you gotta
do is pay five dollars in shipping it's
the uh man fellas the game changer
that's all i'm gonna say
you pop the blue chew and your dick is
on a million
man i'm not saying it makes it bigger
but it feels bigger i'm just saying i'm
not saying but i'm saying
uh look same active ingredient asialis
and viagra
minus the awkward visits to the doctor's
office all right it's all over the phone
it's so easy they ship it right to your
door
in discrete packaging
i don't know if you're going through
erectile dysfunction because you're
stressed out at work uh maybe uh you
just need a little extra hump with wifey
whatever it is maybe you just want to
take a bluetooth and beat your dick like
it stole something just to feel like
damn that shit's hard bruh you know what
i'm saying go to bluetooth.com use the
promo code bootleg right now and you
will save
all money it's free
yeah you'll you'll get a whole month for
free bluetooth.com promo code bootleg
for a whole month for free delivered to
your door discreetly no doctor's
appointments no awkward visits same
viagra cialis ingredients
man what are you waiting for go do that
um but you also just i just saw you were
kicking it with kodak black explain to
me how kodak black ends up hanging out
with all the essays bro man i don't even
know uh it's crazy how life works
like no i'm just messing with you so
check it out he just we we uh i did a
song one of his older homies with um g
thug
he does music too he's from florida you
know what i'm saying he's a zoe
they uh
they came down to paramount to my hood
we did a record
ever since then we just kept we just
kept solid communication and you know
anytime he comes down here we take care
of it we take care of him and if i go
down there he takes care of us g thug or
kodak
okay but the thing about it is is he
comes down he brings all of those right
they [ __ ] with us so it's like
i [ __ ] with thug [ __ ] you know it's like
a [ __ ] with yak same [ __ ] it's like it's
transparency you know what i'm saying
i'mma treat this i'm gonna treat all the
people from from from sniper game from
from the zones i'm gonna treat them all
the same way as i treat g thug with the
same respect you know like as long as he
gives me that
that green light
so like he says he's good he's good he
thug's your guy that that's kodak's guy
that's a yeah that's that's a tommy
right denominator that's his homie and
[ __ ] so where did you have kodak
actually pull up to the hood like where
where where you guys check it out
wasn't it
g thug this last time when uh they were
hearing ferony loud he told me pull up
come in yak
come to the studio you know what i'm
saying i pulled up i was chilling with
them i was chilling with kodak and
gunner when they recorded for his last
album
before he got picked up and then um
i was chilling we we we met and we built
we built that little relationship
i already had a relationship with g thug
it's just a matter of building a
relationship with the whole gang right
with the whole sniper game and everybody
so i met i met i met rico i mean his
cousin jay jader i mean a lot of i met a
lot of people you know big e and then um
they k this he came back down again he
came back down multiple times and we
kept contact so this last time g thug
told me hey uh
kodak's in town he's gonna pull up on
you you know take care of him you know
whatever he needs i was like yeah i got
you you know it's all love he and he
called me like four in the morning and
i'm asleep but i wait i answer the phone
that's g though i already know what time
it is business
so i answered the phone i got you let me
know when he's here pulls up
i was i was at airbnb i was getting
ready to shoot videos
uh kodak facetime me i'm like oh what up
yeah what i'm saying like chico [ __ ] i
told him pull up he pulled up on me and
[ __ ] from there we went to the studio
you know i'm saying he's like i gotta go
to the studio they're gonna pay me 30
000 to listen to beats i said let's go
i'm going with you he said let's go
bring the whole game i brought everybody
with me we went to the studio
you know what i'm saying we in there
chilling with him he made some music and
and yeah you know i'm saying [ __ ] y'all
got a record together [ __ ] something
like that you don't say something like
that so you guys have a song together
yeah well well he sent me the as soon as
we left the studio
he shouts me out on the record and all
that he's showing mad love and then as
soon as we leaving the studio he like
hey swift i know you want that hoe here
give me a phone he airdrops it to my
phone he sent me the record and then i
get hop in my car and listen to record
they got open verse and all that i'm
saying even
[ __ ] so i was just like oh i'm like hold
on
i'm like uh
did this fool ya just send me an open
verse or or or am i tripping and he shut
me out on the song like you know what
i'm saying like i was like hold up am i
am i tripping or or he just sent it to
me to listen to what's going on but yeah
like uh i talked to i called g thug and
he like man jump you better rap on that
[ __ ] fast
i'm saying and do send it yo i'm saying
what are you guys just going through the
process trying to get it cleared and all
that the thing about it is uh kodak told
me he told me he uh he just told me
don't don't leak it he just told me
don't leak it don't put it out the
record and then basically like he's
going through a lot right now when i see
him again i'm going to figure it out
exactly we won't figure it out but
that's not to get it clear it's not a
problem that's not going to be a problem
all right if so well guys i just know
you know sometimes like a company like
atlantic that they could they [ __ ] block
[ __ ] no they like the [ __ ] block but the
thing about it is i'm gonna call yak
like hey man get on your people head and
he's not gonna tell me no because i'm
not gonna tell him that'll be a big look
man no for sure i i i love that man for
[ __ ] with us yeah i'm saying no ain't
nobody out here in l.a was [ __ ] with
us like nobody big and and and yak came
over here and it's just [ __ ] with us
you know i'm saying that's a beautiful
gutter he put up on us by himself
by himself
he came to the airbnb i got like 10 of
my homies for my click right there from
my hood right he pulled up by himself
he's like chico what up
solo in his in his [ __ ] uh in his
jeep that shit's crazy come on man he a
real [ __ ] all these
[ __ ] [ __ ] out here they won't
pull up like on you like that just let
alone your own race right come on man
that shit's crazy man
[ __ ] that's wild
hey any care to comment on the cng crook
one beef going on instagram
man what's going on i don't know man
both both of you guys call my phone you
know what's up
you know both of them right call my
phone man you know what's up man you
guys want to catch a little squad but we
do it in my backyard man it's okay man
we man we have you know we we we agree
to disagree but
yeah it's like both of them are nice
guys what are y'all doing you guys are
both good kids really um i know you just
lost somebody who was a part of the
grimey
grinder
that's the homie from colorado right
colorado yeah parkside yeah so uh
obviously rest in peace to him i i i saw
some of this stuff on like fool
community about that
um was he he was signed to you
you know what he was just down you know
what
we were about to make him official for
grimy records so we had had the
conversation in the past and he was
rocking with me he just had a situation
with another label as soon as they
dropped his album and
he was a free agent you know i jumped on
him like what's up let's rock and roll
he's coming he and he's been rocking
with us he wanted to he every time he
comes down he's tapping in swift what's
the move what we doing right you know
what i'm saying damn that's crazy man i
didn't like obviously everywhere's got
their areas oh he was the future for
sure colorado you i just feel like it's
psyched and he was so different yeah so
different like he bringing he re you
thinking you looking at easy e or
something mexican easy like what this
food was old school but swagged up
and and he swiftly blew approved you
know what i'm saying
what does it take to be swifty bro
you gotta be different you can't be
typical you got to have swag
you got to get money you got to be with
the business
you got to be with the business with the
business
got you though it's crazy because the i
feel like
the you know if you like rewind like to
like the early 2000s the mexican rapture
was so
it was like little rob mc magic it was
very um
very small it was a small like broad
yeah yeah you would see well you would
see like mr capone and like high power
records and all them dudes but i feel
like right now there's like so much
diversity in the scene
and uh
like to see like you know you put the
group album out with with like two of
the other hottest mexican artists like
um
what like what what are your thoughts
just on like the like mexican hip-hop
right now just like and you guys are
just making hip-hop music and happen to
be mexican i feel like
we open the doors
you know me personally i feel like me
personally i feel like i unlocked the
door for
for us to to
do more than what we can do now you know
especially bringing kodak to la and and
rock doing you know rocking with him and
[ __ ] right now and talking to kodak and
telling him hey look lil sway that's
your twin right there he's on the
atlantic you know we're gonna put him on
ktb on sniper gang and we're gonna give
him more leverage with atlantic you know
i'm saying kodak understand what i'm
telling him he knows that they shelfing
him but once they see him [ __ ] with
jack
you know what i'm saying it's a wrap so
it's like that's not you you're you're
you're a and ours your manager couldn't
do that [ __ ] for you swifty blue did
that for you i'm saying and and before i
even told kodak like hey man uh i never
told him let's do a song or nothing
before i told him i didn't even tell me
he shout me out on a song i never told
him no thirsty no weird [ __ ] right but i
did tell him hey you know what you gotta
[ __ ] with suede you gotta [ __ ] with
money sign suede that's little yeah he's
on the atlantic
he's the [ __ ] right now he's on fire
shout out to him what about like have
you been able to tap in with like the
other side of the [ __ ] like a guy like
ogeezy like oh obviously ogzzy's about
to do a national tour that uh
cookies is sponsoring
but i know he's kind of not as heavy on
like
kind of the street [ __ ] as more he's
more cultural he's more on his own [ __ ]
he's like he's like he's he's backing up
who he want to push and [ __ ] he's not on
something like oh i'm gonna do it for
the rasa type [ __ ] you know what i'm
saying right like i'm really i'm really
gonna try to do [ __ ] for my people and
help to help the double ass and [ __ ] he
i think yeah yeah
he's not a he's not a member he's he's
you know i think he's a tiger so you
know what i'm saying yeah i want to say
he's from
i want to say he's from hollywood
hollywood yeah good i mean he's a great
kid man great kid he's successful smart
is good
talk to me about so you know
obviously this outsider thing versus the
guys up north i'm a white dude who did
not grow up in southern california i
grew up in phoenix so we have mexican
gangs mexican mafia you're a mexican
outside now
[Applause]
but obviously out there in the prisons
it's like the mexican mafia right out
here south siders but it's like a real
crazy
beef between is it it's it's the
nortenos and the south siders right yeah
well
well you know what there's just a lot of
history behind it and um
and you know how you know how it goes
sometimes history tends to repeat itself
but um it's toned down a lot it's toned
down a lot but
sometimes people can't get disrespectful
you know that's all it is like it's like
the bloods and the crips it's toned down
a lot you see them interacting right but
sometimes it can be disrespectful you
know like could you ever see yourself
doing a record with someone who's
mexican from northern california not
from the gang but just a northern
california mexican dude i have a record
with baby gas i was gonna say baby gas
is fire you know what okay check this
out like my upstate my upstate
southerners chitoranas the king of
sacramento you know i'm saying he's from
up north oh [ __ ] north sac baby
you know what i'm saying northside king
you know what i'm saying so he so [ __ ]
we got cuerno achivo what i'm saying
he's from up north but he's a he's a uh
uh up
upstate southerner
that's interesting upstairs yeah that's
what you know so you could be from
northern california and still be a south
sider
yep well it's like this we got we we we
so big that we branched out everywhere
we got
we got homies everywhere everywhere you
know even out of state
right and that's obviously that's more
some prison [ __ ] right at least where it
starts
everywhere it goes from the prison to
the streets right yeah but you know like
[ __ ] you go everywhere you see homies
you see [ __ ] la has 13 jerseys is
that you see colorado parkside so you
see the culture you see the homies over
there
that's when colorado um
what did you did you see that what i
mean i'm sure you've you saw it everyone
saw it but what whack was saying about
how he never signed a southsider
you know what
whack um
like
he's right he's like that's it that's
how it is that's it's been it's been you
know what i'm saying it's been
a lot of like
they run their own politics we run our
own politics it is what it is i'm not
mad at him it's just the the way the the
question was asked between him and and
the homie that was talking it was kind
of like the way they asked the question
and the way they got at each other you
know obviously he's going to answer it
yeah yeah if it was me on the phone with
whack i'm not going to ask him would you
sign a south side i don't give a [ __ ] if
you want to sign one we don't want to
sign to know blacks right south siders
do want to guess i don't want to speak
on that but we don't want a science to
know blacks
you know what i'm saying
is that because of the prison [ __ ] it's
not a racist thing help me understand
because when you say that out loud it
sounds crazy it's because like this it's
like this
it's like
i go to jail i rock with my race
i eat with my race i do things with my
race so it's like i'm i'm here out here
i conduct business i do things with my
race you know like i'm we integrate and
whatnot but why would i have somebody in
charge of my music career if if i'm
already
programmed a certain way i'm already
institutionalized a certain way why
would i you get what i'm saying that's
just my mindset so i'm like nah we
wouldn't do that and and most of the
homies would think the same way they're
gonna agree with what i say so you would
sign with somebody
if they were unaffiliated
like let's say diddy wanted to sign you
the bad boy
um
like
me personally i'm not trying to sign me
personally i'm not trying to sign i'll
get somebody else signed and i and we do
some business let's say kodak black what
is it like wanted to make you sniper
games
we're gonna get a little suede on there
you know what i'm saying i'm rocking
with them yeah it's all love i will not
gonna sign sure are you saying that you
wouldn't like strictly because of their
race
because i'm not gonna have it and it's
like this we're gonna we're gonna
negotiate the terms we're gonna make
sure that it's like we we have
it's like 50 50 control type [ __ ] we're
not gonna um
we're not gonna give somebody else let
alone another race full control
okay that's what it comes down to you
but but you get what i'm saying like
it's not no disrespect but it's just
more like it just sounds crazy does
sound crazy sounds a little racist but
you know what you know what that sounds
a lot of racist you know what i'm just
being honest i'm being real i'm being
real like i'd rather go sign with like
even though you think even though you
like you might hear crazy [ __ ] but i'd
rather go sign with like a corrido label
or something you know like some i'm
gonna keep it to the roots i'm you hear
what i'm saying
like if if they wasn't [ __ ] us with
us back then why they [ __ ] with us
now because now we breaking in we're
doing [ __ ] now they're gonna want to
sign us yeah of course [ __ ] all that now
we're gonna stick we're gonna do what we
know best you know what i'm saying but
that's just me and i'm from like i'm
from la i'm from out here from the
streets hypothetically
kanye west wants to sign you to good
music
well i'll be like look we got suede and
peso
like check it out i'm gonna do food's
doing more numbers of me kanye [ __ ] me
we got them on he wants you i'll be like
nah man
you're in the yard
yeah i can't do it i can't
you know what i'm saying so do you work
with black artists yeah i do but it's
it's different though like most of the
time
like we don't have no
no it's not like we're signing anybody
we don't have no full commitment you
know what i'm saying yeah we could work
we could never do business records with
black artists yeah man we got hell yeah
all right so i just want to make i'm not
i got black i'm trying to i'm trying to
make you sound less racist than how
you're sounding no that it's just
it sounds bad what you're saying so
listen when you're in prison you said
look i'm institutionalized this is what
it is obviously you've done a lot of
time right you've been i've done enough
time just you've been in you've made up
my mind you've done enough time to make
up my mind when you're in when you're
incarcerated in california the mexicans
are with the mexicans
black people are in southern california
right yeah so it's a little different so
black people are locked up with
usually do they politic with it's like
this look
is it the others the
it's it's the cause there's the others
yeah they got the others the brothers
outsiders yeah exactly like indian
whatever and then and then the the um
the whites and the mexicans
the woods the south siders they run with
the south side so while you're in prison
you're running with the the woods the
peckerwoods
yeah we run together the woods run what
[ __ ] crack off like you know what i'm
saying they stick together okay so when
you're in jail you're a lot you're a lie
you're alliance with the white guys
right that's like you're you're you're
okay so you're saying some of that but
that has nothing
but
i have none against the black man this
last time i was in in la county i was in
a hoover dorm man i was i was uh and
it's a mutual dorm right i had to say
that first it's a mutual dorm so there
was no there was no empty bunks on the
south side on the south side
on racks so i had to get a bunk one of
the empty bunks were on the hoover racks
you know what i'm saying on the black
racks and [ __ ] i had no problem with it
like you know what i'm saying like
it was a mewtwo norm [ __ ] it was cold
like
you know what i'm saying right and and
i'm not gonna lie it was hot like
everybody in there strapped up ready for
riots to crack off just because
like it's a lot of traffic well i heard
the l.a county jail's like well [ __ ]
just god-awful place it was it was
almost 24 it was 24-hour lockdown almost
seven days a week i heard it and where i
was at in that dorm in the 5000 floor
but you get what i'm saying is just
intense in there man yeah yeah it is
intense it is intense because everybody
in there you might be cool with somebody
in there but once you hit the yard if
you're getting transferred to prison
then you that might be your enemy in
like [ __ ] six months right yeah vice
versa exactly like you might have beef
with someone in the county but then once
you're on in prison that's your partner
and then and then nine times out of ten
two it's like [ __ ] um
you gotta you gotta learn how to
like how to have respect and and learn
to live with other you're going to be
sell that with somebody you got to learn
to live with somebody you know and
there's a lot of wild [ __ ] in the la
county for the homeless people
your sally will get mad because
because um
you know you don't clean you don't clean
right or something just little things
like that [ __ ] around try to stab you or
something you know because you ain't
cleaning your bunkers on me [ __ ] like
that yeah jesus have you ever have you
ever had to use a roll of toilet paper
as a pillow yeah
i had one bad night in jail
toilet paper is a pillow goddamn okay so
just so we're clear
you are not a racist guy no not okay i
just want to be clear not at all now
that we're on the other end of that
because
it just sounded really bad initially so
i just want to make sure
if i was racist man you wouldn't be i
wouldn't allow kodak to pull up i
wouldn't allow [ __ ] um i wouldn't do
no music with rob too you're just saying
that if you had your choice you would
sign with somebody who's also latino
because yeah exactly because you know
because you know we come from the same
place they don't understand my struggle
and how i came up you know so that's
fair i mean better
okay that's fair all right when we post
the clip post that we cleared that up
we cleared that up hey we got to stop
the interview real quick to tell you
about our partners our family at odd
socks go to
oddssocksofficial.com right now
and the promo code bootleg kev it'll get
you 20 off the fly of socks in the world
[ __ ] spongebob
[ __ ] cheez-its
a little bit of pepsi
uh how about how about some underwear do
we like underwear e.t boxers let's go
ahead and just open up a pair of these
boys so you can see how fly the draws
are ladies and gentlemen because they
are fly by the way they just gave me my
own pair of odd socks go on my social
media and you could see them uh i don't
know if they're going to be for sale
because let's be honest
who wants to wear socks with my [ __ ]
ugly face on them besides my wife and
she don't even want to wear them there
we go
they got the draws they got it all man
get the odd socks basics which i love
just the basic boys these are amazing
comfy socks on socksofficial.com use the
promo code bootleg kev save 20 off let's
get back to the interview what are you
working on i mean obviously you you did
you finally dropped the spanish album
yeah we dropped we dropped the song with
d smoke we dropped the song with melee
mel and we're dropping uh we're dropping
the albums is releasing tonight
officially out tonight yeah i know you
would be playing me some stuff from it
because you've been working on that for
a while right yeah man we worked on that
for like like about a year and a half
ago two years ago yeah because i heard
it a while ago yeah before you got
locked up i want to say yeah yeah but
that's that's cool we sat on it you know
and it's uh full spanish you're are you
rapping in spanish both spanish and
english mellie mel from uh dr dominican
republic i heard she's um i heard she's
a madam
she's dope she's no i heard i heard
she's a madam
like what does matter mean i heard she's
out there pimping pimping oh [ __ ] i
heard she got i heard she got a stable
in the diarsky she
she i don't know what she got going on
but [ __ ] i'm pretty sure she got it
popping you going can you go to the dr
um i'm pretty i think so i think so you
go to mexico often i do go to mexico
often which parts do you like to
frequent well [ __ ] i just go around the
corner like doritos rosarito [ __ ]
essentia um spend any time in timon
um
i well on the way back i pull up
sometimes go get somebody's cause and
[ __ ] but i like going like rosarito and
[ __ ] roger rita's i got i got i got a uh
my father-in-law stays out there so i'll
go visit him and [ __ ] oh nice nice
that's cool he likes to get drunk so
you're a man are you married
i got kids i got kids so your ba that's
your baby mama's dad yeah might as well
be married
once you got kids with somebody and like
you're still like you know he might as
well just know what was [ __ ] you right
but i'm rapping and [ __ ] and things
going good so i'm kicking it yeah yes
how many kids you got i don't need no
long-term commitments um i got i got two
kids two kids
what's it like having swifty blue as a
father is it is are you are you strict
are you pretty are you the cool dad oh
no that's for the kids to decide
you let like you let them watch what
they want like are they
are you like no that's a pg well i let
them play grand theft auto well then
that's all you need to know
if you point to the side and say listen
son when i was uh going crazy
this is how we would do things
you have you're probably pretty good at
grand theft auto that's how you deal
with it check it out yeah that's this is
how you deal with it check it out that's
how you look up the cheat codes yeah
um what else like obviously the spanish
album comes out tonight uh
i know you're always working i know
you're always shooting videos what's
next like i was after this
you know what
all right we're already we're trying to
line that up with a little suede get
them over there with kodak sniper gang
in there yeah get them some leverage
with the label um other than that
we're working on a tour working on a
tour you know
what i'm saying
brick wolf pack cap g suede peso
that's gonna be crazy shout out to cab g
cap she's a great yeah so so it's just
crazy ideas but we we talked a little
bit about it you know we all support
each other we all on board so we're
gonna get so we're gonna get a bag and
we're gonna run it there
okay go run that [ __ ] up uh new videos
coming i'm sure no videos and we just
dropped a video with suede and grimey
records it's called all-star team
what's up with grammy records like do
you have uh
any i know you have artists under you
but like are they assigned to you are
you always looking for new talent yeah
you know what we're always open to
working with new artists and basically
uh every artist on the label you know we
got a situation we got a situation going
on
well shout them out who's on there who's
got anthony rick the savage
god uh doe boy 909
lil show
and and those and i'm a fool and those
are the ones those are the ones that we
right now focus working on that's the
most fire rap name i'm a fool i'm a fool
oh he's a he's a fool wait till you meet
him there it is man well listen swifty
blue appreciate you pulling up go run up
his uh spanish album you got a bunch of
music obviously you on now go uh stream
all his [ __ ] because you get to keep you
i mean platforms there it is man swifty
blue with the blue lemonade
whoa